i'm going to do one more video where we
compare our old and new definitions of a
projection now our old definition of a
projection
onto some line l of the vector x
is the vector
in l
or that's a member of l
such that
x
minus that vector minus the projection
minus the projection onto l of x
is orthogonal
is orthogonal to l so the visualization
is if you have your line l like this
that is your line l
right there and then you have some other
vector x that we're going to take the
projection of it onto l so that's x
the projection of x onto l this thing
right here is going to be some vector in
l so it's going to be some vector in l
such that when i take the difference
between x and that vector it's going to
be orthogonal to l so it's going to be
some vector in l this was our old
definition when we took the projection
onto a line some vector in l maybe it's
there and if i take the difference
between that and that this difference
vector is going to be orthogonal to
everything in l
it's going to be orthogonal to
just like that
just like that so this right here would
be its difference vector that would be x
minus the projection
of x onto l and then of course
this vector right here this is the one
we were defining it that we were
defining it that was the projection
projection onto l of x now what's a
different way that we could have written
this we could have written
we could have written this exact same
definition we could have said it is the
vector in l such that
so we could say is let me write it here
in purple is the
vector
v
in
l
in l
such that
v
let me write it this way such that x
x minus v right x minus the projection
of l is orthogonal let me write it is
equal to w
which
is
orthogonal
to
everything
in l
being orthogonal to l literally means
being orthogonal to every vector in l so
i just rewrote it a little bit different
instead of just leaving it as a
projection of x onto l i said hey that's
some vector v in l so this is some
vector v in l such that x minus v is
equal to some other vector w that's that
other vector w which is orthogonal to
everything in l or we could write it we
could rewrite that statement right there
as
x is equal to v
plus w
so we could we could just say that the
projection of x onto l is the unique
vector v
in l
such that x is equal to v plus w where w
is a
unique vector i mean it is going to be a
unique vector in the orthogonal
complement of l right this has got to be
orthogonal to everything in l so that's
going to be a member of the orthogonal
complement it's going to be a member of
the orthogonal complement of l so this
definition is actually completely
consistent with our new subspace
definition and we could just extend it
to
arbitrary subspaces not just lines let
me help you visualize that
let me visualize that so
let's say i have some let's say we're
dealing with r3 here
let's say we're dealing with r3 right
here and i've got some subspace in r3
and let's say that subspace happens to
be a plane i'm going to make it a plane
just so that
it becomes clear that we don't have to
take projections just onto lines so this
is my subspace
v right there and let me draw its
orthogonal complement let's say it's
orthogonal complement and it looks
something like
that let's say it's a line
and then it goes it intersects right
there then it goes back and of course it
would have to intersect at the zero
vector that's the only place where a a
or a subspace in this orthogonal
complement overlap and then it goes
behind and then you can see it again but
obviously you wouldn't be able to see it
again because this plane would extend in
every direction but you get the idea so
this right here is the orthogonal
complement of v that line
now let's say i have some other
arbitrary vector in r 3 here so let's
say i have some vector
that looks like that let's say that that
is x now our new definition for the
projection of x
the projection
of x
onto v
is equal to the
unique
vector
v this is a vector v that's a subspace v
the unique vector v
that is a member of v
such
that such that
x
is equal to v
plus w
where
w
is
a
unique unique member
of the orthogonal complement of v this
is our new definition so if we say x is
equal to some member of v and some
members orthogonal complement we can
visually understand that here we could
say okay it's going to be equal to let's
see on v it'll be equal to that vector
right there and then on v's orthogonal
complement
you add that to it so if you were
shifted over you would get that vector
just like that this right here is v
that right there is v and then this
vector that goes up like this out of the
plane orthogonal to the plane is w and
you can see if you take v plus w you're
going to get x and you can see that v is
v is the projection
the projection
onto the subspace
capital v so this is a vector v
is the projection onto the subspace
capital v
of the vector x so the analogy to a
shadow still holds if you imagine kind
of a light source coming straight down
onto our subspace kind of orthogonal to
our subspace the projection onto our
subspace is kind of the shadow of our
vector x so hopefully that helps you
visualize it a little bit better but
what we're doing here is we're going to
generalize it here i you know we i
earlier in this video i showed you a
line this is a plane
but we can generalize it to any subspace
this is an r3 we could generalize it to
rn to r100 and that's really the power
of what we're doing here it's easy to
visualize it here but it's not so easy
to visualize it once you get to higher
dimensions and actually one other thing
let me show you that this new definition
is pretty much almost identical to
exactly what we did with lines this is
identical to saying that the projection
projection onto the subspace x is equal
to
is
is equal to
some
unique
vector
in v
such
that
such that
x
minus the prediction
onto v of x
is
orthogonal
is orthogonal
to
every
member
of v because this statement right here
is saying
any vector that's orthogonal to every
any member of v says that it's a member
of the orthogonal complement of v so
that statement could be written as
x minus the projection onto v of x is a
member of
v's orthogonal complement or we could
call it sum w so if you call this your v
and if you call this whole thing your w
you get this exact definition right
there you would have w
is equal to x minus v
and then if you add v to both sides you
get w plus v is equal to x we defined v
to be the orthogonal the the
projection of x onto v w
is a member of our orthogonal complement
and i don't want to get confused this is
the orthogonal
v the vector v is the orthogonal
projection of our vector x onto the
subspace capital v i probably should use
different letters instead of using a
lowercase and uppercase v it makes the
language a little difficult
but i just wanted to give you another
video to give you a visualization of
projections onto subspaces other than
lines and to show you that our old
definition with just a projection onto a
line which was a linear transformation
is essentially equivalent to this new
definition on the next video i'll show
you that this
this for any subspace is indeed a linear
transformation